[Musique]
vous pensez quoi de l'arrivée des
trottinettes à toulouse mais j'aime pas
parce que je n'avais pas conduis la
trottinette et aussi sa rencontre des
pollutions pour l'électricité
je viens de séville espagne on utilise
beaucoup le vélo mais dans le
centre-ville là trottinent et c'est
maintenant un peu nouveau aussi comme
dans leur cité europe et
ça et vos soeurs ils en pensent quoi
encore vos soeurs l on pense qu'on veut
c'est un mâle ashton
mais las ketchup et
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse écoutez je pense
pas que tout soit aussi peuplé que aussi
pollué que ça maintenant il faut
demander tout ce qui habite toute
l'année ici
moi je viens ici comment plaisir une
fois par semaine à peu près vous habitez
ou à la base j'habite dans un petit
village du lot qui s'appelle montcuq et
vos frères ils habitent là-bas aussi
j'ai pas de frère oui tout à fait on
habite la bastille en effet on a grandi
à montcuq coiffé ou je tiens à dire à
tous les gens qui s'amusent à dire
montcuq c'est pas très drôle c'est
montcuq mexique
tout le monde est bienvenu à montcuq
montcuq monkey pas excusez moi what is
your opinion de pollution in toulouse
[Musique]
système
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rosbif on est des rosbifs aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]